on
[Musique]
rires
kouici mais seulement la bienvenue à
paroles autochtone alors à cette semaine
je suis en déplacement je parie pour
devenir et jamais ou est ce que je suis
mais ça reste que c'est une semaine
importante c'est la semaine de recurt
math rock des mocassins donc ces
mouvances qui existent un peu partout en
amérique du nord et c'est aussi simple
que d'apporter ses mocassins et de
mettre le mot clic en dessous de la
photo pour pouvoir célébrer le fait
d'exister encore devoir se représenter
culturellement plusieurs endroits que ce
soit à la maison au travail ou en voyage
donc cette semaine comme l'événement
dépasser journée du 15 novembre est
devenue la semaine du 15 novembre vous
allez voir à travers la semaine
plusieurs personnes mettre justement
leurs mocassins en ligne et le mot-clic
habituellement assez rare qu'un home box
rock des mocassins ou gros comme à 2021
et c'est une manière de pouvoir se
rassembler d'être fiers et de pouvoir
représenter les cultures autochtones à
travers le monde parce qu'il faut
montrer qu'on est quand même encore ici
aujourd'hui on est fier de pouvoir
montrer notre culture à tous partout
alors je vous souhaite une très belle
semaine oubliez pas de rocky vos
mocassins et de les mettre en ligne pour
que mon puce board ou move n'est alors
c'est une belle semaine